president trump has fired his
administration's top
election security official who declared
the 2020 vote
to be fair and accurate kris krebs was
director of the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency
created after russia interfered with the
2016 election
the president made a series of voter
fraud claims
unsupported by evidence in a tweet that
announced the firing
wii xi zhang is at the white house wija
was this seen as a surprise
good morning anthony you know for the
last week there was speculation that
krebs job
would not survive because he was so
vocal
in disputing president trump's false
claims that the election was rigged
after krebs is firing yesterday he
seemed to suggest he had
no regrets about speaking up tweeting
honored to serve
we did it right department of homeland
security official christopher krebs
became the latest member of the
administration to be fired by tweet
last night president trump posted that
he terminated krebs
as director of the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency
you should have confidence in the
integrity of the process
krebs has publicly defended the
integrity of the november
election just last week his former
agency signed on to a statement
contradicting the president's baseless
claims about election interference
writing there is no evidence that any
voting system deleted or lost
votes changed votes or was in any way
compromised
krebs's firing came as new election
drama
unfolded in michigan this is a disgrace
a public zoom call turned tense after
two republican canvassers in wayne
county
which includes detroit initially blocked
the move to certify
election results shame on you shame on
you
for leading to this level of corruption
you have disavowed
your right to even sit in the seats that
you occupy
the canvassers claimed votes in the
polling book did not match the tabulated
votes but officials say that discrepancy
can be common when turnout is high
and it doesn't necessarily mean votes
were improperly cast
or counted you talked about not
certifying detroit
even though you acknowledged that
livonia a city by the way
i know you know is 95 white had bigger
variances
than detroit which is 80 black the panel
ultimately changed
course unanimously certifying the
presidential results
still president trump praised the
attempt to challenge the results
tweeting having courage is a beautiful
thing
the trump administration has refused to
cooperate
in the transfer of power to
president-elect joe biden
but senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell claimed the transition would
be smooth
despite the delay we're going to have an
orderly transfer
from this administration to the next one
and on the floor of the senate
republican lindsey graham who has not
publicly acknowledged the election
results joined
other senators congratulating vice
president-elect kamala harris
on tuesday biden met with his own
national security experts
as the president continues to block
access to government officials
i've been unable to get the briefings
that ordinarily would have come by now
the trump administration is moving ahead
with withdrawing troops from afghanistan
and iraq the acting defense secretary
christopher miller
announced that the number of troops
would be cut down to 2500
in each country by mid-january u.s
allies and even members of the
president's own party
are warning now is not the right time to
pull back
arguing the taliban has not met any
conditions to justify
a reduction like cutting down the amount
of violence
or breaking with al qaeda tony all right
we should thank you very much